everybody
it has been 10 long
annoying years
this right here is for all the laker
fans around the world
this one right here is for all the laker
haters around the world
but most of all this is for colby
yeah yeah
yes we told you
we tried to tell you we tried to give
you a warning
i'm coming for all of y'all
making his triumphant return to brother
from another o'shea jackson jr
first question shea how many bottles did
you go through
last night in this morning uh 10
10 for every year that we were away from
our home
the nba finals i'm so happy you know the
the rest of these single-digit having
championship
teams trying to steal larry from us
larry o'brien and you know i'm glad he's
finally back home there's a reason why
the lakers logo
is a gold ball because that's what
that's the top of the trophy right there
we
are we are everything about the nba
i'm i'm happy for the first female owner
to win a chip
genie bus we knew it was always going to
be you therefore i mean
it's written it's written already
so hey o'shea other than the the final
buzzer
and and the championship being official
what was your favorite moment of this
entire run give me your favorite moment
it's got to be it's gotta be anthony
davis
hitting that shot game two against
denver
that was like his you know that was his
his big shot bob moment
you know that was my mom said that was
his laker moment
you know that's when he got his purple
and gold armor that day
and you need moments like that
because if you if you if you think about
also danny green
has a huge part of that moment if danny
green doesn't go
and get that offensive rebound that ends
up giving us another possession
then you know that that series you know
it could have been
we still would have won but i don't want
to play any more games
but i have to and yeah that's that
moment right there
seeing rondo fall out this last game
i hated rondo i hated
aggressive like i couldn't stand
and then once he became a laker i
started getting
these weird feelings and and rondo's
laker moment
was a buzzer beater against the celtics
last season
and so for him to come in and get the
job done
17th plato for the celtics back in the
day then comes to the lakers and it
gives us our 17.
he is like the weirdest chapter of that
rivalry
and i love him to death now
well well you know it's funny wasn't
that long ago when lebron got there shay
and it was like
oh you ain't kobe kobe's the king of l.a
remember there was some folks that i
think you know
vandalize a mural or something like that
um yeah
and even lebron talked about it yeah
exactly
i know posers outside agitators that's
who that was right
you're right but even lebron
uh what even lebron said like laker
nation doesn't care
what you've done until you do it here
you know so how do you view lebron now
he was one of yours before but now he's
really one of yours how do you view him
now versus
before we won this championship yeah you
know i was
one of those people who not you know as
soon as he got here
i always described it like if darth
vader uh hits you up and is like yo i'm
trying to kick it with joe squad
you don't really you know downplay him
come on through whatever you're trying
to do we'll do it
and uh you know with lebron it was
it was game one i think it was the 2017
finals but game one
uh when the warriors had got durant
and it's in golden state it's the one
where j.r smith
uh had that play oh yeah yeah in that
game
lebron had like 51 and 51
8 and 8. i remember thinking
i'm never going to hate on this man ever
again in my life
like it's just unreal he's unreal
and he's efficient and he does
think plays ahead his his basketball iq
is unreal that's why getting a team with
him and rondo
on it is almost unfair but lebron
bringing the chip to the purple and gold
all i really want is for 2k to finally
put him on the all-time lakers because
they cheating us
i really don't understand why kawhi
leonard and paul george get to be on the
all-time clippers
but i can't get lebron now that he got a
chip i'm expecting
the ultimate lineup of magic kobe braun
kareem and shaq stop cheating us and
start treating us
okay
you